[Musique]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous
regardez et maintenant l'émission qui
revient avec plaisir et avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui autour de cette table nous
avons sélectionné les meilleurs ils ont
l'oeil vif et le verbes haut et non pas
peur du débat je vous présente mes
invités soient bonjour rédactrice en
chef au service politique du magazine
Marianne vous avez écrit la dictature
des vertueux pourquoi le moralement
correct est devenu la nouvelle religion
du monde s'est publiée chez bucher
Chastel c'est une première pour vous
ravi de vous accueillir à côté de vous
n'attend de verre bonjour bonjour
première également écrivain et
philosophe vous êtes l'auteur des liens
artificiels c'est à retrouver chez Albin
Michel et Virginie Riva également une
première pour vous bonjour ravi de vous
accueillir vous êtes journaliste
politique chez contexte et le grand
Philippe manières était avec nous
bonjour communiquant président de VS
Solis sur renvoie à votre dernier livre
le pangolin et l'ISF comment le monde
d'après nous rend tous fous vous avez
publié ça aux éditions
observatoire dans cette émission on se
demandera si l'intelligence artificielle
menace notre démocratie si l'ultra
gauche menace notre République on verra
si Adrien cadenas c'est une menace pour
l'avenir de la nupes et puis et puis
décidément quelle semaine les amis on
essaiera de savoir si Emmanuel Macron
est une menace pour lui-même et pour la
suite de son quinquennat mais d'abord
merci président Larcher seul nous sommes
nous trop présomptueux sur la scène
internationale cette semaine le chef de
l'État en tout cas provoqué un tollé
auprès de nos alliés occidentaux de
retour d'un voyage en Chine Emmanuel
Macron appelé l'Union européenne à ne
pas être suiviste des États-Unis ou de
la Chine dans le dossier de Taïwan face
à l'incompréhension de nos amis
américains il a précisé sa pensée
quelques heures plus tard écouter la
France est pour le statu quo à Taïwan
la France soutient la politique d'une
seule Chine et la recherche d'un
règlement pacifique de la situation
c'est d'ailleurs la position des
Européens
et c'est une position qui de tout temps
a été compatible avec le rôle d'Allier
mais c'est justement là que j'insiste
sur l'importance de l'autonomie
stratégique être alliée ne signifie pas
être vassal c'est pas parce qu'on est
allié qu'on fait des choses ensemble
qu'on décide de faire qu'on a plus le
droit de penser tout seul simplement je
ne participe pas de l'escalade verbale
qui peut exister chez certains qui
consisterait à faire de toute urgence
pour nos politiques en quelque sorte
soit la politique fiction consistant à
nous demander qu'est-ce qui se passe si
ce qui est le meilleur manière que ça
arrive Philippe c'est une mauvaise
semaine pour la diplomatie française oui
enfin une mauvaise semaine comme les
autres parce que diplomatie française on
ne peut pas vraiment dire qu'elle brille
il a mais là ce truc est
particulièrement choquant c'est
d'ailleurs intéressant parce que quand
il corrige le tir le président dit la
France est pour le statu quo c'est très
clair vous allez rire ceux qui sont pour
le statut quo c'est précisément nos
alliés c'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
comme son nom l'indique et ceux qui
voudraient que ça change ce sont les
Chinois donc à partir du moment où vous
dites que vous êtes pour le statu quo
vous choisissez votre camp et c'est
précisément ce qu'il n'a pas fait quand
il était là-bas sur un sujet super
sensible où chacun sait que le conflit
peut exploser à n'importe quel moment
communication vous le communiquez en
vous qualifiez ça de dehors de
communication je ne surestime pas la
communication c'est très important la
communication sinon je ne m'en occuperai
pas mais il y a pas que ça cirque c'est
peut-être une erreur de communication
mais c'est pire c'est une erreur au fond
c'est à mon avis vraiment une une énorme
gaffe et qui nous met à dos alors une
fois de plus une grande partie de nos
allées traditionnelles falloir les
réactions en Allemagne aux États-Unis
les gens se demandent ce qu'il a pris
c'est l'évidence que le camp du bien
même s'il a des tas d'inconvénients
c'est celui du statu quo c'est donc
celui des alliés et le camp du mal c'est
ceux des bellicistes c'est ce de ceux
qui veulent envahir Taïwan donc ne pas
choisir son camp c'est commettre non
seulement une bourde diplomatique
majeure mais une erreur morale une faute
morale c'est une bombe c'est une gaffe
Virginie en diplomatie je pense que oui
parce que le problème c'est la il parle
peut-être que sur le fond le constat
peut-être discutable le problème c'est
de le dire comme ça dans l'avion et il y
a l'idée en plus ça renvoie à cette idée
du louvoiement du président dans ces
alliances et notamment en lien avec la
Russie le fait d'avoir toujours jusqu'à
un certain point entendu la main à
Vladimir Poutine dans l'espoir d'un jour
pouvoir et devoir négocier avec lui à sa
table donc il y a effectivement ça
renvoie à cette même idée dans
louvoiement avec les puissances qui est
assez dommageable pour la vie française
on va voir cette interview qu'il a donc
accordé aux échos dans lequel il dit
avons-nous intérêt à une accélération
sur le sujet de Taïwan non la pire des
choses serait de penser que nous
Européens devrions être suivi sur ce
sujet et nous adapter au rythme
américain il y a une surréaction
chinoise Nathan qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette déclaration d'Emmanuel
Macron si vous remplacez le mot Taïwan
par Ukraine c'est ça et que vous vous
placez avant la guerre en Ukraine
c'était les phrases des proposines en
fait qui accusait l'Amérique d'être
responsable de l'accélération il me
semble qu'il faut arrêter de rigoler et
que il faut réfléchir sur la base des
réalités depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine
il y a clairement tous les empires
autoritaires et libéraux qui ont compris
que leur velléité territoriale
de conquête pouvait en tout cas qui
pouvait y donner libre cours la Chine a
participé clairement depuis un peu plus
d'un an d'une escalade manifeste à
Taïwan et accusé si vous voulez les
Américains d'être responsables de cette
de cette escalade c'est de l'inversion
accusatoire total et je trouve pour le
dire en un mot que il y a une
contradiction absolue entre le fait de
soutenir l'Ukraine face à la Russie et
de ne pas soutenir Taïwan parce que
concrètement il faut pas
ergoter ça c'est une phrase qui consiste
à ne pas soutenir Taïwan voir à donner
libre cours en fait à la Chine en disant
vous faites ce que vous voulez même si
ça brille derrière la notion de statut
cool là clairement c'est ça si vous
voulez il y a une contradiction totale
soit on est du côté des petits
territoires qui sont démocratiques même
s'il y a des problèmes qui sont menacés
par des empires soit on est du côté des
empires et du droit du plus fort on peut
pas être du côté de la démocratie en
Ukraine et du côté du droit en plus fort
en Chine c'est impossible il y a une
forme de cohérence parce qu'il a mis
très longtemps à être du bon côté
ukrainien vous allez sur le fond mais
vous voyez ce que voit un problème de
forme aussi c'est surtout ça parce qu'il
a rectifié ses propos on voit quelques
jours plus tard il a rectifié ses propos
le chef de l'État en parlant du statico
est-ce que il y a eu est-ce qu'il a
parlé trop vite dans l'avion encore une
fois il était dans l'avion avec des
journalistes en off comme on dit et il
accordait cette interview
il y a toujours avec Emmanuel Macron de
toute façon la question du des moments
auxquels il parle c'est jamais très bien
calibré c'est à dire que là
effectivement il est dans l'avion il est
après une visite en Chine donc ça donne
enfin au milieu d'une visite en Chine
donc ça donne vraiment l'impression que
c'est la voix qu'il a entendu et qu'il
répète ce qu'il a entendu mais ça
rejoint une conviction d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est à dire que effectivement il a il a
loué sur certaines questions mais il y a
quand même toujours l'idée de chercher
alors la troisième voie goienne
difficile à trouver surtout en 2023
puisque les conditions géopolitiques
sont pas du tout les mêmes mais il y a
une tentative et en ça c'est intéressant
de voir qu'Emmanuel Macron et c'est
toujours de tenir ça surtout dans un
contexte européen où on sait bien des
des Européens comme des Polonais par
exemple sont très ont besoin de la
protection des États-Unis c'est
intéressant de voir ça dans la mesure où
nos voisins allemands eux sont
totalement dépendants de la Chine pour
leur commerce donc c'est le le tentative
de cette troisième voie vous qui vous
paraît plausible possible est-ce que
vous êtes tous d'accord à cette table
est-ce qu'il y a une troisième fois
possible entre
les Chinois et
l'empire américain non seulement
moralement on peut pas discuter un
instant enfin c'est vraiment une
pathologie française de trouver aux
Américains tellement de défauts et il y
a encore une fois beaucoup de défauts
aux États-Unis et dans les diplomatie
américaine mais leur trouver tellement
de défauts que toute dictatures lui
seraient préférable aux États-Unis
en donnant un mot allemand qui aurait
précisément dit ce que je veux dire
c'est une vision du monde qui est
malheureusement assez traditionnellement
l'occasion je vais vous raconter une
anecdote j'ai un de mes amis et Narc qui
faisait sa mobilité au Quai d'Orsay
n'est pas du Quai d'Orsay mais il y est
pendant un an mais ton et puis il avait
observé que très souvent la France
faisait des des dons alors au Nicaragua
tel pays etc on donne énormément
d'argent à l'état de pays et chaque fois
il demandait au secrétaire général mais
alors pourquoi on fait cette comprendre
et chaque fois le secrétaire général lui
répondait écoutez c'était une histoire
ancienne donc il y a prescription je ne
je ne cite pas de nom vous avez écouté
c'est parce que tel pays est
nous avons un problème vous avez ce
monde fou qui explose de partout les
États-Unis n'ont absolument pas leur mot
à dire et pendant ce temps Macron c'est
un ami et avec la Chine en train de lui
lécher le cul
dans le texte pourquoi cette réaction de
nos alliés bon là c'est trop important
mais d'autres réactions pourquoi cette
réaction aussi
offensive de nos alliés est-ce qu'on
touche là le sujet ruptif ce qui se
passe à Taïwan c'est le sujet 2023 le
sujet de 2024 peut-être même le sujet de
2025 ça a des conséquences énormes sur
et pas seulement sur la sur la zone
Indo-Pacifique mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que Emmanuel Macron
c'est pour ça que je voulais réagir à ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure ce qui ce
qui se passe aussi c'est que il a la
mémoire longue il se souvient de ce qui
s'est passé avec la crise des
sous-marins vendu à l'Australie vous
souvenez avec qui devait être vendu à
l'Australie et puis finalement ça s'est
pas passé de cette façon là donc c'est
aussi une façon de dire de dire aux
Américains est-ce qu'il explique
d'ailleurs très bien je trouve lors de
sa seconde conférence de presse au pays
il est il explique bien on est des
alliés mais on n'est pas des vasseaux
c'est ça qui laissait tenir le problème
c'est que sa déclaration je pense
s'adresser plutôt aux Américains mais ça
s'est retrouvé comme une déclaration
d'allégeance aux Chinois et c'est en ça
que ça passe pas Virginie vous comprenez
quelque chose à la politique étrangère
d'Emmanuel Macron mais là où je ne
comprends pas et je vois une dissonance
énorme c'est que il y va en Chine il va
avec la présidente de la Commission
européenne
il ne cesse
de dire en européen ils vantent les
mérites de l'autonomie stratégique et
c'est d'ailleurs au nom de ça qui défend
qui renvoie d'oiseau Chine et États-Unis
et là il fait une réponse
franco-française en réalité il a heurté
certes Donald Trump et beaucoup de
conservateurs aux États-Unis mais il a
aussi heurté tous nos partenaires
européens parce qu'en réalité cette
position n'est pas concertée cette
interview n'est pas concertée et donc
dire que il renvoyait doigts d'OE 2
puissance
on peut pas dire que ce soit une
position qui est plus puisque
effectivement comme le dit je crois que
c'est le wastrid journal qui disait il
se prend pour le De Gaulle du 21e siècle
donc cette position de Franck tireur qui
a certes permis en d'autres périodes au
moment de la présidence française du
Union européenne de faire émerger des
narratifs comme il dit et l'autonomie
stratégique il a remporté ce combat
c'est vrai depuis 5 ans la souveraineté
européenne le discours de la Sorbonne
personne n'y croyait vraiment il a
remporté ce combat mais il peut pas le
porter seul c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que vous vous dites que
voilà il s'aligne finalement sur les pas
de De Gaulle mais est-ce qu'on a encore
les moyens de nos ambitions mais surtout
moi je ne pense pas que de Gaulle ça
consiste à estimer que un empire
l'empire américain qui est par ailleurs
ces zones d'ombres puissent être mis sur
le même plan qu'un régime totalitaire
c'est pas ça la troisième voie gaulienne
la troisième voie gaulienne c'est le dos
de termination des petits territoires
qui lui a valu parfois je pense au
Québec etc mais c'est ça la troisième
voie gaulienne c'est pas du tout une
forme de real politique cynique et si
vous voulez mini quoi c'est le contraire
moi il y a quelque chose quand même qui
me frappe j'aurais pas dit la chose avec
les mots de Donald Trump naturellement
mais c'est quand même la complaisance de
certains politiques français envers le
régime chinois complaisant ce qu'on a vu
il me semble-t-il de manière très
manifeste pendant la crise sanitaire où
il y a eu en France beaucoup de gens qui
ont fait l'apologie de mesure absolument
totalitaires qui étaient adoptée en
Chine il y a on sait des gens qui sont
très très comme Monsieur Raffarin qui
sont très favorables aux régimes au
régime chinois et si vous voulez dans
cette affaire je pense que trouver une
troisième voie gaulienne on peut le
faire dans un certain nombre de terrains
on peut le faire au Proche-Orient on
peut le faire en Afrique on peut le
faire en Amérique du Sud mais le faire
dans un territoire comme Taïwan ce n'est
absolument pas gaullien c'est plutôt
bien c'est qu'il faut prendre position
dans des sujets aussi sensibles qui
menacent certains de nos intérêts c'est
ça oui puis si vous voulez il y a quand
même il y a quand même une difficulté
c'est avoir une fois avec tous les zones
d'ondes c'est une bonne expression tout
tous les défauts qu'on sait que les
États-Unis ont ils sont quand même le
gendarme du monde et le leader naturel
du monde libre et en face de ça vous
avez pour faire simple des méchants donc
dire
de la Corée du nord de l'Iran ce sont
des méchants ce sont des puissances
agressives qui sont qui ont une
propension à l'impérialisme à
l'extension vers leurs voisins
documentés que les États-Unis ont
notamment certaines visées impérialistes
aussi c'est pas tout à fait quand on
parle des Ouigours on parle pas tout à
fait de même sujet quand on parle de
l'Iran qui pour faire simple encore une
fois j'y vais à la serpe occupe le Liban
on parle pas tout à fait de la miss
c'est on est vraiment pas dans le c'est
vraiment à mon avis une erreur
d'interprétation et encore une fois une
faute morale que de dire on a le choix
entre deux camps qui sont l'un et
l'autre modérément irréprochable oui ils
ont ils sont l'un et l'autre très
prochaine mais il y en a qui sont malgré
tout aussi imparfaits soit-il soit-elle
des démocratie des pays libres et puis
vous avez des pays totalitaires et on ne
peut pas au nom de la supériorité
intellectuelle française qui voudrait
toujours être plus supérieur au
manichéisme et pas tomber dans le piège
du
c'est celui-ci ou c'est cela dire je
suis entre les deux non si si on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas ne pas choisir entre
des gens des gens imparfaits mais qui
sont l'incarnation de la liberté et des
gens objectivement critiquables à peu
près sur tous les critères
Emmanuel Macron
c'était génial qui qui nous parlait
Emmanuel Macron pensait peut-être
pouvoir échapper à l'actualité nationale
et au dossier des retraites en
s'envolant vers d'autres cieux mardi il
a donc pris un avion direction les
Pays-Bas pour un voyage de deux jours et
là-bas patatras il a été chahuté par des
manifestants écoutez
[Musique]
une démocratie est précisément un
endroit où l'on peut manifester où l'on
peut avoir ce type d'intervention dans
son pays
comme dans le monde entier il y a des
endroits où la démocratie n'existe pas
nous ne devrions pas comparer
précisément à cause de ces situations
nous pouvons ne pas être d'accord sur ce
qui devrait accompagner la démocratie
parce que vous votez et vous élisez des
gens
soient peut-être trouver un refuge à
l'international c'est raté et je crois
qu'il en trouvera pas c'est à dire que
cette réforme des retraites va marquer
toute la suite de son quinquennat et
donc qui soit à l'étranger qui soit en
France on voit bien que ça va être un
sujet récurrent les Français sont
majoritairement contre cette réforme
donc il va y avoir des des moments comme
ça des pouces alors effectivement à
l'étranger ça tombe pas parce que au
Pays-Bas on soit hyper au fait de ce qui
se passe en France sur cette réforme des
retraites d'autant que l'âge de départ à
la retraite au Pays-Bas si je me trompe
pas je crois que c'est 67 ou 68 ans mais
là on voit bien bon c'est un grand
classique de toute façon pour avoir
suivi des présidents de la République à
l'étranger il y a toujours un sujet
national qui vient percuter d'autant que
vous vous trimbalez avec des
journalistes français qui sont très
intéressés par l'actualité française
donc c'est un grand classique ça
n'arrive jamais qu'un déplacement se
déroule comme prévu en revanche ce qui
est sûr c'est que pour Emmanuel Macron
qui essaie et on en parlait à l'instant
d'imprimer à la fois une espèce de force
française qui essaie de défendre une
souveraineté européenne concept qu'il a
qui défend à longueur de discours c'est
c'est une vraie sape pour son autorité
des retraites des Français opposés à la
fin de retraite mais je vais vous
montrer ce sondage qui mesure la
popularité d'Emmanuel Macron seul 25%
des Français accorde aujourd'hui leur
confiance au président de la République
pour affronter efficacement les
problèmes qui se posent au pays soit 71%
des Français ne lui font pas confiance
donc 43% pas du tout il y a une
personnalisation aujourd'hui une attente
de la colère sociale à l'encontre du
chef de l'État en dehors même de la
réforme des retraites des retraites il y
a quelque chose qui qui se cristallise
autour de ces personnes aujourd'hui oui
c'est sans doute d'ailleurs le défaut de
la Cinquième République c'est que d'un
côté elle accorde trop peut-être en tout
cas énormément de pouvoir à la figure à
la personne du président sachant qu'une
élection présidentielle c'est une
élection très confuse parce qu'on va
être à la fois pour un programme et on
ne un électeur n'est jamais d'accord
avec la totalité du programme on vote en
même temps pour des compétences
individuelles on vote aussi pour le CV
d'un individu et on va aussi c'est c'est
il faut le dire c'est réel il faut on
vote aussi pour le physique des choses
totalement si vous voulez contingent et
qui n'ont rien de politique mais la
réciproque c'est que de fait souvent
dans l'opposition on fait de lentilles
présidentialisme donc on va critiquer la
figure de Nicolas Sarkozy la figure de
François Hollande la figure d'Emmanuel
Macron je donne l'exemple de François
Hollande parce que c'est intéressant de
voir que on peut avoir des critiques sur
la politique qui a pu être la sienne
mais que quand on regarde quand même les
grands moments qui ont été ceux où sa
popularité s'est effondrée c'était sur
des raisons qui étaient pas du tout
toujours politique et donc là je pense
que les méthodes d'Emmanuel Macron sont
naturellement extrêmement critiquables
mais que ce serait dommage de
personnaliser trop le débat parce que sa
personne en fait importe peu
politiquement ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
à ce niveau là que les choses se jouent
Virginie et pourtant on voit
qu'effectivement qu'il y a une colère
profonde visiblement à l'encontre
d'Emmanuel Macron comment vous expliquer
ça oui la méthode le problème c'est ce
que nous dit un peu Nathan je pense que
le problème est originel déjà au début
du second quinquennat puisqu'il le sait
il n'y a pas eu de campagne donc il n'y
a pas eu alors certes il y a cette haine
concentrée sur la personne d'Emmanuel
Macron mais moi je crois plutôt que
au-delà de la haine il y a un problème
de début de quinquennat donc c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas purgé tous les grands
sujets tous les leaders syndicaux nous
le disaient tout le monde disait c'est
attention si on ne parle pas des sujets
ça va exploser
Emmanuel Macron a décidé de ne pas faire
de campagne contre une partie de son
entourage d'ailleurs et donc les
Français n'ont pas délibéré non pas
questionné ils ont dû élire Emmanuel
Macron aussi parce qu'il y avait Marine
Le Pen et effectivement cette colère
sociale n'a cessé n'a cessé de monter
donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui alors
comme le président a fait sa campagne
malgré tout avec un slogan qui était
avec vous donc effectivement une méthode
qui est censée être renouvelée qui avait
tiré les leçons des gilets jaunes de la
du mépris des corps intermédiaires du
dialogue raté avec des collectivités
territoriales les syndicats on se
retrouve en fait un an après avec un
président élu qui pense avoir un mandat
clair impératif celui des retraites
alors qu'en réalité tout c'est très
discutable puisque est-ce qu'il a
vraiment été élu sur cette seule
proposition qui était de la
triangulation vis-à-vis de la droite au
moment où il a été élu il se retrouve
donc à dire aujourd'hui j'ai été élu
avec ça si vous vouliez un président
différent il fallait dire quelqu'un
d'autre si vous vouliez une retraite à
60 ans et donc il a pas de vrai mandat
il a une vraie colère à l'origine il y a
un problème quinquennat au début
vous êtes d'accord avec ça alors
modérément parce que je pense vraiment
effectivement il y a eu tellement peu de
campagnes il y a tellement peu de débats
que le seul sujet sur lequel il soit
sorti c'était vraiment il est sorti
c'était vraiment les retraites et donc
je pense qu'il est complètement
recevable à dire écoutez vous m'avez élu
vous savez
le clavier que j'allais faire cette
réforme si vous mélisiez et donc j'ai
cette légitimité moi je crois qu'il y a
un effet de résonance entre deux choses
il y a une critique de de la procédure
parlementaire moi je trouve parfaitement
mal fondé c'est à dire que tout ça est
dans la Constitution 49-3 etc bon je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on fait griller à
ce président à cette exécutif en
particulier d'avoir utilisé les méthodes
qui ont été utilisées pendant la
procédure puisque ce sont des choses qui
encore une fois sont parfaitement
constitutionnelles et qui sont très
traditionnels et qui ont été énormément
utilisés et j'ajoute pour un sujet dont
en plus on savait dès le début qu'il
serait traité par le président puisque
ce rejet que je trouve mal fondé et un
rejet qui est probablement mal fondé
mais pour le coup c'est pas discutable
qui est le rejet de la personne du
président certes pour les mêmes raisons
effectivement vous avez complètement
raison on est dit quelqu’un pour des
raisons contingentes entre autres donc
il a été élu entre autres on vit dans
une société médiatique superficielle
matérialiste
narcissique et donc je pense qu'une une
des raisons principales enfin importante
de l'élection du Président il y a 6 ans
et de c'est qu'il a un côté beau doué
qui qui est impressionnant et qui est
désirable
la jalousiement quand ça se retourne
quand vous vous sentez maltraité à tort
ou à raison quand vous vous sentez un
petit quand vous sentez quelqu'un qui a
du mal à accéder à ce à quoi il à ce
qu'il espère à ce et bien vous pouvez
vous retourner complètement contre cette
figure qui semble en fait l'incarnation
de l'inatteignable vous êtes frustré de
votre position sociale vous avez
l'impression que vous pourrez pas en
sortir
c'est normal que cette symétrie c'est à
dire que on apprécie quelqu'un qui est
beau qui est doué qui est manifestement
une belle incarnation mais le jour où on
a l'impression qu'on est dans une espèce
de rejet de ces aspirations il est pas
complètement incompréhensible qu'on se
retourne contre la figure de
l'inaccessible ça vous paraît pas
Emmanuel Macron par Nicolas Sarkozy où
il y a eu un il y a eu un moment aussi
de défiance vis-à-vis de Nicolas Sarkozy
mais en tout cas non moi le problème
principal pour moi c'est pas ça le c'est
le c'est le moment c'est à dire il y a
une sorte de de de de
triturisation de du corps social le
corps le corps social a été tourné dans
tous les sens par un Emmanuel Macron qui
a pas voulu entendre les signaux des
signaux d'alerte parce que par exemple
la crise des gilets jaunes c'était pas
prévisible alors certains sénateurs
d'ailleurs l'avaient repéré en disant
mais si regardez vous allez avoir un
gros problème vous l'avez dit à Gérald
Darmanin qui est à l'époque au compte
public et qui avait dit NON NON cette
taxe carbone ça va très bien se passer
il y aura aucun problème
et donc les sénateurs lui explique ça
mais sinon il y a pas il y a pas des
alertes dans le pays en disant attention
on va avoir les gilets jaunes là ça fait
quand même quatre ou cinq mois que la
plupart des observateurs des
syndicalistes des responsables de partie
disent attention ça ce n'est pas
possible de faire la réforme à 64 ans à
un moment où il y a de l'inflation où
les gens sont encore beaucoup du covid
où il y a juste ce contexte
international dont on parlait encore
tout à l'heure c'est vraiment pas le
moment d'infliger ça en plus aux
Français et la fatigue que ressent les
sondeurs aujourd'hui quand ils
interrogeaient français et vient aussi
de la c'est pourquoi ça en plus
maintenant et je pense que c'est ça le
rejet en plus du moment je rajouterai
qu'il y a une erreur de stratégie
politique puisque vous dites le 49-3
parfaitement constitutionnel certes mais
alors il ne fallait pas passer son temps
à dire que on allait surtout pas
l'utiliser parce que ils se sont
eux-mêmes une balle dans le pied en
rendant l'objet illégitime alors qu'il
est totalement légal et totalement
depuis 2008 inscrit dans la Constitution
et en plus ils sont relap parce que
maintenant ils disent on le fera plus ce
qui est complètement naturel
allez on avance qui dit ça
l'exécutif
on va prendre des nouvelles de la nuit
pS Je sais pas si vous en avez eu cette
semaine les élus de la France insoumise
ont voté pour le retour du député Adrien
katnin son rappelle qu'il avait été
condamné mi décembre à 4 mois de prison
avec sursis pour violence conjugale mais
de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts c'est en
tout cas ce que nous dit Alexis Corbière
écoutez-le moi je peux comprendre que
certaines personnes disent qu'il fallait
pas son retour mais il y a aussi
certains qui considèrent que la sanction
politique je parle pas de cette
judiciaire ayant été ce qu'elle était
une fois qu'elle est accomplie bon c'est
l'idée philosophique derrière ça que
vous faites une faute je fais une faute
politiquement une décision moi je
souhaite pas en venir mais les choses et
je souhaite que notre union continue et
c'est une leçon qui est faite certaines
de nos partenaires nous critiques
j'entends c'est respectable mais
continuons nous avons un programme qui
nous permet d'avancer Nathan à ce que la
réintégration d'Adria catenens vous
choque écoutez si j'avais été dans
l'entourage d'Adrien catenin ça ne s'est
conseillé ou quelqu'un du parti du
mouvement j'aurais sans doute été d'avis
qui lui fallut qu'il démissionne qu'il
se représente et ensuite que les
électeurs tranchent de savoir s'il
fallait qu'il reste députés ou non mais
bon il n'a pas fait ça et il me semble
quand même que dans un état de droit
quand un individu commet un délit ou un
crime que il est condamné à une peine et
qu'il purge ça peine qu'à partir de là
il faut qu'il ait une réinsertion
sociale c'est le tout début des
Misérables c'est quand Jean Valjean sort
du bagne on compare pas quatre nains ça
Jean Valjean mais quand Jean Valjean
sort du bagne et qu'il n'a pas si vous
voulez son et qu'elle allait se
passeport qui l'empêche d'aller frapper
aux portes parce que les gens savent que
il a été bannière dans sa vie et que
donc ça l'essentialise moi je suis
contre une conception essentialiste de
la justice c'est-à-dire consistant à
estimer que un acte qui a été puni par
la loi vient si vous voulez définir
l'intégralité de la personne qu'il a
commise et il y a un lien d'ailleurs
avec ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
la 5e République c'est que dans les deux
cas c'est une forme de personnalisation
du débat il me semble que ce qu'il faut
combattre c'est des actes là en
l'occurrence des actes de violence des
actes illégaux des actimmo mais pas si
vous voulez en ayant cette vision
complètement presque même métaphysique
comme ça d'une souillure sur
l'intégralité de l'occurrence c'est une
décision politique c'est à dire que
évidemment Adrien cadenas continuait à
siéger en tant que député non inscrit
donc la France insoumise n'était pas
obligée de prendre cette décision ça se
dit que c'est un mauvais signal aussi
pour le droit des femmes disons que la
question dans tout ça il y a ce que vous
venez d'exposer et qui est totalement
juste après il y a la question politique
ce qui est très intéressant
souvenez-vous pourquoi François Fillon a
tant de difficultés quand la faire
Pénélope surgit parce que c'est lui qui
avait dit qui imagine le général de
Gaulle mis en examen en attaquant
Nicolas Sarkozy pourquoi cette affaire
catenens offre une énorme difficulté à
la France insoumise c'est parce que ce
sont eux qui se réclamaient plus
vertueux que les vertueux et qui
expliquaient que dès que dès qu'il y
avait la moindre le moindre soupçon sur
quelqu'un il fallait l'écarter réfléchir
tous les tous les parties ne disaient
pas ça eux ils étaient quand même les
plus maximalistes sur ces positions là
et donc la difficulté c'est se trouver
ensuite confronté confronter cette
parole qui est préexister aux actes et
donc pour ce parti c'est très compliqué
je pense que ça aurait été moins
compliqué pour pour d'autres parties qui
n'avaient pas eu ces positions là et
puis il y a aussi Adrien cadenas c'est
un très proche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
on voit bien
le regard différent qui est porté sur
quelqu'un en fonction de sa distance par
rapport au chef et ça je trouve ça
problématique mais je parle d'un point
de vue politique après je suis
totalement pour la réhabilitation etc
des personnes condamnées une fois
qu'elles ont accompli leur peine mais là
la question n'est vraiment sur la
politique sur l'exemplarité et donc je
pense qu'il aurait dû prendre un peu
large à définitivement mais revenir plus
tard politique et problématique aussi
selon vous
moi je pense que la décision politique
en fait en l'absence de cadre législatif
effectivement puisque il y a pas de loi
Aurore Berger a voulu faire passer une
loi sur une éligibilité justement des
personnes qui ont commis et des élus qui
commettent des violences elle a même pas
eu la majorité pour enfin sa propre
majorité donc à l'absence de loi c'est
sûr que ça renvoie la responsabilité
individuelle soit du l'individu enfin du
qui décide de démissionner comme vous le
disiez très bien soit du groupe
politique le groupe politique décide
d'organiser un scrutin dont on
connaissait d'ici en réalité puisque
Soizic vient de le dire catenens c'est
le fidèle d'entre les fidèles de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans leur petit saut
briquet révolutionnaire qu'il se donnait
entre eux c'est Saint-Just c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'adore c'est il
l'avait adoubé
réintégré selon vous c'est parce que
c'est un proche de Jean-Luc c'est
totalement clair puisque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est la figure tutélaire qui
qui effectivement ajoute le groupe on
voit qu'il y a eu 15 votes contre on
peut à peu près recouper c'est votre
compte avec ceux qui ont été d'ailleurs
évincés de la direction de la France
insoumise les Corbières les coquerelles
les hautains peut-être les ruffins et on
voit que cette décision politique créer
une scission déjà à l'intérieur de la fi
et puis après au sein au sein de la nups
mais oui c'est sa proximité avec le chef
qui fait que ce scrutin était totalement
pipé tout le monde connaissait l'issue
de l'issue du vote ce qui vous êtes
d'accord il y a pas de souci
je dirais quand même deux petits
éléments en complément d'abord enfin il
a tout de même été élu il a des
électeurs et moi je trouve qu'il faut
quand même pas oublier que ces électeurs
méritent d'être présentés dans les
meilleures conditions possibles alors on
sait que la procédure parlementaire
c'est quand même mieux d'être dans un
groupe et que moi je pense ce serait la
France insoumise je me préoccuperai un
peu tout de même de la de la juste de la
bonne représentation des électeurs d'un
de mes principaux députés puis alors
j'allais dire un point de vue esthétique
pour finir je suis en désaccord avec une
très grande partie de ce que dit Adrien
katas mais je trouve que c'est un très
remarquable orateur et et il apporte
vraiment quelque chose à la vie
parlementaire à mes yeux et je pense que
même si encore une fois on peut siéger
en un compris je trouve que c'est pas
mal qu'il reprenne la plénitude de de
ses capacités dans le cadre du jeu
parlementaire il apporte quelque chose
au jeu parlementaires
s'il n'avait pas purgé sa peine on est
je le répète pour pas qu'on me repose
sur l'avoir dit rien de tout ce que j'ai
dit n'aurait la moindre pertinence si on
était dans un cas pénal avec quelqu'un
qui avait pas purgé sa peine donc la
question aujourd'hui elle est purement
et finalement politique et justement
chez les alliés des insoumis la décision
a suscité énormément de réactions
écoutez en fait cette décision elle nous
a fait changer de période dans cette
affaire au mois de septembre on a vu une
affaire cadenas maintenant on est une
affaire et des filles et les filles
Mélenchon en réalité c'est à dire que
c'est plutôt catenas qui est en cause
que la décision qui a été prise hier par
les députés de la France insoumise
Adrien c'est pour au moins trois raisons
la première d'avoir giflé sa femme
évidemment la deuxième pour sa défense
qui était catastrophique et qui était
une injure à plein de femmes victimes de
violence et la troisième c'est de nous
infliger son retour
bon les ce qui connaissent bien Jean-Luc
Mélenchon savent que ce sera pas si
simple que ça même question est-ce qu'il
y a aujourd'hui une gauche anti
Mélenchon qui est en train de se créer
sous nos yeux à la suite de cette
nouvelle cette nouvelle division autour
de l'affaire 4 Nans je sais pas si c'est
une gauche en stimulant change je sais
pas c'est plutôt la question de l'avenir
de la nups disons que ceci n'est pour
moi qu'une crise un révélateur l'affaire
catenens effectivement je l'ai dit sa
proximité avec Mélenchon explique cette
attitude là mais je crois qu'au-delà de
ça c'est surtout
quel est l'avenir puisque là en fait il
y a plus aucun projet commun en réalité
pour la nuit Pesse si vous prenez toutes
les échéances électorales LFI est
totalement sous les radars les
sénatoriales les européennes les
municipales dans les trois cas elle est
fin n'est pas en position hégémonique
comme il était au moment des
présidentielles et des législatives donc
ils n'ont plus cette force
d'entraînement au sénatorial ils n'ont
aucun grand électeur exactement ils le
savent d'ailleurs ils réclame presque
rien il s'excuse presque de venir aux
réunions aux européennes ils ne sont
absolument pas majoritaires parce que
les ce sont les écologistes qui sont la
première force normalement au Parlement
et enfin les municipales même sujet là
ce sont plutôt les socialistes qui ont
la main donc quels sont les projets
fédérateurs pour la nupaise là les
échéances électorales qui pourraient les
ressouder et faire taire ces divisions
il y en a pas donc LFI c'est sa question
plutôt c'est même pas celle de Mélenchon
c'est celle de l'hégémonie de LFI au
sein de la nups pour moi qui se pose on
attend vous êtes d'accord oui sur
l'analyse politique je suis tout à fait
d'accord et qu'il y ait des cueillés
aujourd'hui on le voit des gens qui qui
en veulent à Jean-Luc Mélenchon au sein
de la France insoumise au sein de la
news plus largement c'est une évidence
mais mon avis il faut quand même
réfléchir aux arguments là qui sont
invoqués moi je ne comprends pas pour je
fais écho au sujet que vous avez montré
je ne comprends pas comment on peut être
de gauche et être contre la
réhabilitation sociale et humaine des
gens qui ont été condamnés par la
justice je veux dire si on applique ça à
d'autres situations dans les grands
débats notamment sur les questions
sécuritaires le la perspective de gauche
je caricature un petit peu en disant
cela mais c'est précisément d’estimer
que quand quelqu'un sort de prison ou
quand quelqu'un a purgé sa peine il
redevient un citoyen à part entière et
qu'il ne faut pas lui mettre un saut
d'un famille sur la tête donc et
d'ailleurs je fais une parenthèse pour
dire que à la France insoumise avant
l'affaire katnas là-bas même il y avait
des gens pour dire que la réhabilitation
sociale dans certains cas il fallait
quand même
réenvisager tout cela donc à mon avis il
y a aussi derrière une grande crise
intellectuelle de la gauche ça veut dire
qu'il y a une partie de la gauche qui
peut soutenir en fait un discours qui
est un discours sécuritaire qui est un
discours entre guillemets jeu caricature
toujours mais un discours entre
guillemets de droite et on le voit sur
d'autres sujets aussi me semble-t-il
donc le problème si je résume ce que dit
Nathan c'est pas un problème Mélenchon
c'est un problème plus général un
problème idéologique Philippe vous êtes
d'accord oui mais je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce que vient dire Nathan
c'est à gauche se marchent sur les pieds
dans ce cas particulier mais au nom de
la vertu c'est amusant que son surnom
soit Saint-Just c'était vraiment cette
espèce de vertu qui écrase tout y
compris les valeurs pour des raisons à
la fois tactiques et d'obsession
d'aliénation quasiment mais je suis
intéressé moi de voir qu'on a fait un
détour pendant notre échange sur
l'Ariège et puis que finalement on est
revenu à 4 NAS parce que c'est notre
sujet inspirez-vous mais je me demande
si dans le fond il y a pas une vocation
un peu de de rideau de fumée dans cette
affaire à 415 parce que le vrai
phénomène politique la vraie chose moi
que je trouve hyper importante c'est
cette élection en arrière c'est-à-dire
que pour tous ceux qui désespérément
parce qu'on n'a pas tous suivi
il y avait moi j'ai pour la gauche une
vraie affection je pense que les valeurs
dont elle est porteuses sont extrêmement
utiles au débat public et mérite d'avoir
voix au chapitre mais à condition d'être
exprimé sur un mode qui soit à la fois
républicain etc pourquoi être en voie de
disparition on avait l'impression que
chaque fois quand quelqu'un portait une
voix de gauche raisonnable civique
respectueuse c'est bâillé par la
démagogie de la partie la plus à gauche
de la gauche et en particulier la France
insoumise la défaite de cette candidate
qui à mon avis incarné spécialement bien
ce que j'appelle le mal à gauche par
battu par quelqu'un qui était soutenu
par les quelques-uns dans la dans la
gauche républicaine qui eux ont échappé
[Musique]
une qui était soutenu par elle et les
filles et qui était pour le dire
rapidement un peu bizarre voilà et puis
il y en a une autre plus classique et
qui a gagné et donc moi je trouve que
c'est tout à fait rassurant de voir que
peut-être on a enrayé cette succession
de mauvaises nouvelles j'appelle moi
mauvaise nouvelle le fait de constater
que la démagogie la veulerie en
politique l'emporte sur
les voies des macronistes et du
rassemblement national
on est vraiment dans un écosystème assez
particulier
très difficile je pense d'extrapoler
alors on est c'est vrai que c'est on se
contente de sondage en ce moment donc
c'est toujours mieux une élection on va
dire mais il y avait pas une très très
forte participation donc c'est compliqué
de mariage
j'ai le sentiment que c'est la fin de on
ne pouvait que broyer du noir quand on
pensait à la gauche avec un esprit
républicain jusqu'à cette élections mais
qui m'a redonner un petit espoir préféré
thème la question accompagné cette
semaine politique plusieurs responsables
pointent du doigt les discours et les
pratiques de certaines organisations
écoutez
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ce que la
LDH a incarné je ne comprends plus
certaines de ces prises de position
cette incompréhension n'est pas nouvelle
elle s'est fait elle s'est fait jour
dans ses ambiguïtés face à l'islamisme
radical et elle s'est confortée depuis
quelques mois les manifestations ont
démontré qu'il existe aujourd'hui des
groupuscules extrêmement violents
extrêmement organisé
contre lequel le gouvernement semble
impuissant et qui attendent à l'ordre
public et donc à la tranquillité de nos
compatriotes on voit bien qu'il y a une
complicité notamment de l'ultra gauche
de l'extrême gauche quand des élus par
exemple mère parlementaires à
Sainte-Soline vont avec leur écharpe
tricolore dans une manifestation qui
n'est pas déclaré voire dans d'autres
manifestations interdites mais je pense
que en réalité il manque à leur devoir
délurépublicains et je pense qu'à un
moment donné trop c'est trop et ça
suffit soyez que c'est quoi l'ultra
gauche explique-nous ce que c'est que
l'ultra gauche alors en fait ça dépend
de qui parle c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est parce que là on voit
le choix qui a été fait par le
gouvernement
la question suivante ils ont deux
positions complètement différentes
Gérald de Darmanin joue-t-il
actuellement un jeu dangereux d'un côté
on a Nathan de l'autre Philippe Nathan
allez vous allez commencer vous allez
lui dire pourquoi selon vous Gérald
Darmanin joue en ce moment un jeu
dangereux vous avez 45 secondes face à
Philippe ça va pas être facile bon
courage allez-y c'est pour moi que ça
peut être ça écoutez il me semble quand
même que là le macronisme refuse de
trancher entre l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite sachant qu'on a une
extrême droite qui est quasiment en
porte du pouvoir qui a été donné comme
tel qui a été donné élu dans un récent
sondage et on a un gouvernement qui a
décidé que les allaient taper sur
l'extrême gauche entre guillemets en
employant des termes qui sont contraires
à l'esprit républicain quand on parle de
terrorisme qu'on confond l'opposition
une opposition critiquable si l'on veut
mais avec du terrorisme qu'on joue sur
ces craintes quand on critique la LDH
qui date de l'affaire Dreyfus qui a
peut-être des positions dont on peut
discuté mais qu'on la critique on remet
en cause c'est subventions si vous
voulez tout ce climat là faites un
climat qui me semble me semble-t-il fera
avez peut-être dans deux ou trois cent
ans les historiens définiront le
macronisme comme une préparation de
l'avènement de l'extrême droite en
France
superbe
Nathan vous allez nous répondre à ça
Philippe vous êtes l'avocat de Gérald
Darmanin vous avez 45 secondes
je suis ma paradoxalement d'accord avec
beaucoup des éléments de de ce que je
viens de me dire Nathan en particulier
cette histoire de Ligue des droits de
l'homme est lunaire et c'est une faute
après on a affaire un ministre qui vient
de la droite dans un gouvernement qui
est plutôt plus à droite qu'à gauche sur
ces questions de sécurité qui est
agressée par des manifestants qui ne se
comportent pas comme des manifestants et
le fait de savoir si cette opportun ou
pas de pointer l'ultra gauche plutôt que
le ta droite bah ça me semble de second
ordre c'est un fait que que ce soit de
gauche ou de droite il y a des ultras
qui en veulent aux institutions qui en
veulent à la société qui menace de ce
point de vue la société et les
institutions dont j'allais dire en tout
cas c'est l'histoire des institutions
l'exécutif et le gardien je pense que
tous les moyens sont bons pour rappeler
l'attention des gens sur le fait que
c'est un réel danger et peu importe que
ce soit l'ultra gauche une droite ce
sont des ultras ils sont condamnables il
faut les condamner elle est match nul
Virginie quand on entend
sur l'ultra gauche c'est quoi c'est un
peu la nuit pêche aussi qui est visée
dans la bouche de Gérald Darmanin oui
mais c'est ça qui est très dangereux en
fait dans son jeu c'est que il désigne
par il semble en fait faire l'amalgame
entre ultra gauche et LFI alors qu'en
réalité elle a fit c'est une gauche
parlementaire qui combat l'usage de la
violence dans l'histoire d'ailleurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est très clair mais
même pour en avoir parlé récemment et
des insoumis ils disent très clairement
nous à la rigueur les antifas on veut
bien parler avec eux mais Black Bloc
anarchiste absolument pas alors pourquoi
parce qu'il considère que la violence
n'est pas opérante pour pour remporter
les combats sociaux qu'ils portent donc
en fait
les antifas ne sont pas dans cette dans
la violence que dénonce Gérald Darmanin
mais en tout cas Gérald Darmanin il fait
appel à un imaginaire qui est celui des
années de plomb
celui du sang enfin du terrorisme les
années de plomb action directe
aujourd'hui LFI effectivement vous
l'avez dit il y a certes du de la
bordélisation pour reprendre les termes
du ministre mais on ne peut absolument
pas mélanger ces imaginaires et en plus
que je trouve dangereux c'est que c'est
une bataille politique et culturelle de
Gérald Darmanin qui vient de la droite
et qui ne veut pas se fâcher avec une
partie de l'extrême droite donc il tape
sur l'extrême gauche plutôt que tout
taper sur l'extrême droite alors qu'au
même moment justement on a une bataille
culturelle en cours pour faire de
l'extrême droite une droite dure
banalisée le débat existe dans toutes
les rédactions doit-on parler encore
d'extrême droite je l'ai vécu dans
certaines rédactions alors aujourd'hui
on parle de droite dur jameloni on n'ose
même plus parler d'extrême droite mais
là encore Célia l'histoire de l'Italie
c'est que la vraie menace elle est
plutôt du côté de l'ultra droite la
bataille culturelle elle est en train de
se jouer de l'autre côté et là Gérald
Darmanin ouvre un autre feu une autre
bataille culturelle qui à mon avis est
beaucoup moins légitime sur les
institutions et la violence dans la rue
c'est pas une bataille culturelle c'est
autre chose c'est le respect des
institutions et du jeu démocratique il
n'y a pas à part à part sur la question
de la légitimité du conseil
mais c'est le fait de faire la magame
avec elle et fille parce qu'à part sur
la question du Conseil constitutionnel
et l'épisode des perquisitions de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on ne peut pas dire
qu'il y a un appel à l'insurrection et
on en respect de nos institutions
d'ailleurs la question est plutôt posée
aux écolos c'est à dire que ils sont
traditionnellement non violents pour
certains pour la déozobéissance civile
et il se retrouve embarqué dans une dans
une manifestation avec des gens qui qui
ont des qui ont des armes et qui ont
envie de s'en prendre qui ont envie d'en
découdre et de s'en prendre aux forces
de l'ordre donc la question d'ailleurs
on l'a posé dans Marianne cette semaine
aux écolos et ils sont très embêtés ils
ont ils expliquent qu'ils ont pas de
lien évidemment avec les individus
violents mais ils voient bien qu'il y a
la doctrine est en train de de bouger
que l'intérêt se fait notamment autour
de personnalités comme Andreas malme qui
a fait un tour un tour des des j'allais
dire des popotes mais des rédactions
puisqu'il est il venait défendre son
livre en France c'est un Suédois il a
rien à voir avec Greta Thunberg lui il
prône le sabotage le sabotage comme
comme un outil et donc le vent poupe en
ce moment c'est ce que vous nous dites
la question de la violence là en ce
moment elle se pose aux écolos pourquoi
ben parce qu'il y a des aides parce
qu'ils essaient de défendre ils essaient
de se battre par exemple contre les
contre les méga bassines qui à mes yeux
méritent de poser la question est-ce
qu'on a encore besoin de de ces méga
bassines donc il pose des questions qui
sont importantes mais ils sont débordés
par des éléments qui viennent en partie
de l'étranger sur des sur des sur des
questions de violence donc c'est c'est
eux qui ont ce problème là aujourd'hui
et si le vrai péril les amis pour notre
République tenait en deux lettres
Ia pour intelligence artificielle vous
avez sans doute entendu parler de chat
GPT un outil de langage basé sur
l'intelligence artificielle est
disponible en quelques clics sur
Internet il permet de rédiger des poèmes
et de trouver des blagues pour les
déjeuner du dimanche en famille mais il
peut aussi être utilisé pour diffuser de
fausses infos pour manipuler l'opinion
publique ou encore propager des discours
de haine le patron du logiciel met en
garde écouter le
on doit être très prudent je pense que
ça ne marche pas d'essayer de tout
permettre cela dit je pense que les gens
devraient être content de voir que le
monde a un peu peur de tout ça vous avez
peur vous personnellement si je disais
le contraire vous devriez soit ne pas me
croire soit être inquiète que je
travaille dans cette industrie on attend
expliquer nous moi j'y comprends presque
rien l'intelligence artificielle très
simplement qu'est-ce que c'est
alors l'intelligence artificielle en un
mot et sans mot technique c'est tout
simplement l'ensemble des technologies
qui consistent à reproduire ou à imiter
des opérations qui normalement sont des
opérations mentales et donc ça découle
de toute une représentation d'abord
philosophique de ce que c'est que
l'esprit
représentation qui estime que l'esprit
c'est le fait de recevoir de contrôler
de réguler de manipuler des informations
donc à partir de là alors évidemment je
comprends que ça fasse peur on a tous
utilisé chat GPT sans doute pour tester
et c'est vrai que le fait de voir qu'une
machine peut faire mieux que nous des
choses dont nous pensions que seul notre
esprit était capable c'est tout à fait
normal que ça puisse susciter des
frayeurs mais je pense que c'est
frayeurs passent complètement à côté du
sujet en fait ce qui est passionnant
c'est que l'intelligence artificielle
elle nous révèle de la même manière que
la révolution technologique industrielle
au 19e a montré que la vie manuelle
était une vie extrêmement mécanique et
que donc des machines pouvaient s'y
substituer sans problème et bien
l'intelligence artificielle nous révèle
que les trois quarts de notre vie
mentale et d'ordre mécanique quand au
quotidien on lit la presse quand on
discute avec des gens quand on écoute à
moitié une conversation quand on écrit
des mails administratifs tout ça est
mécaniques donc me semble-t-il
l'intelligence artificielle ça doit être
une invitation à repenser complètement
le champ d’abord le champ de notre
conscience et deuxièmement le chant du
travail du travail intellectuel vous
avez pas peur très clairement si on a un
débat qui a la hauteur du sujet et que
vraiment on voit toutes les implications
sociales économiques même philosophiques
de cette révolution ça peut mener au
contraire à des émancipation formida
Philippe
on y reviendra sans doute moi ce qui me
fait peur c'est le jeu que peut jouer
dans leur débat démocratique l'usage des
fake news des fausses images vous pouvez
tout faire maintenant vous pouvez
greffer comme on sait la tête d'une
personne connue sur un acteur porno vous
pouvez le représenter en train de
toucher une manette de cash de quelqu'un
des images d'Emmanuel Macron
de Donald Trump on est dans une aire de
crédulité et donc ça moi ça me fait
assez peur pour le reste moi je serai
complètement à ce qu'a dit Nathan ce qui
est frappant on va justement aller dans
le sujet un peu dans le sujet c'est
qu'en fait l'intelligence artificielle
et cette particularité qu'elle est ni
artificielle ni intelligente elle est
pas artificielle c'est-à-dire que pour
être intelligente si on va aussi tout
dépend ce qu'on appelle l'intelligente
mais pour pouvoir faire ce qu'on lui
demande elle est bourrée de Data
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on la bourde
data qu'on est obligé de mettre à jour
en permanence parce que le
fonctionnement fondamental de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est que
par exemple pour vous produire un texte
elle vous dit à chaque mot quel est le
mot qui est le plus probable contenu de
la requête statistiquement c'est-à-dire
qu'elle mouline tout ce qui préexiste
tout toutes les oeuvre mais alors avec
un peu de retard c'est à dire que si
vous lui demandez un truc c'est passé il
y a 15 jours elle peut pas répondre mais
ça n'est que ça donc ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas artificiel c'est c'est la
reproduction de ce qu'on lui a donné il
y a pas de d'autonomie si vous voulez
puis c'est quand même modérément
intelligent c'est vrai que pour que ça
marche il faut lui demander des choses
assez simples donc le résultat est très
spectaculaire mais vous pouvez pas lui
demander de réfléchir à quelque chose de
très complexe en revanche quelque chose
qui peut paraître complexe parce que ça
mobilise des facultés
qu'on n'a pas forcément tout au même
moment dire vous pouvez avoir un
résultat spectaculaire je voyais tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure un poème qu'on
m'a montré tchat gepetty s'il te plaît
démontre moi qui est un nombre infini de
nombre premier en rime et hop dans la
seconde vous avez un truc de 20 lignes
qui rime ou on vous démontre c'est pas
très inquiétant c'est pas du tout
inquiétant je reviens sur ce que disait
Nathan hein c'est c'est spectaculaire
bon c'est pas très utile et deux c'est
pas du tout inquiétant ce qui est
inquiétant c'est ce qu'on peut en faire
dans le débat public encore une fois en
prétendant montrer quelque chose qui
n'est pas et ça c'est très troublant en
démocratie pas évident est-ce que vous y
voyez une menace pour notre démocratie
pour notre espace public en général
non il y a une question et je trouve
qu'on se la pose pas c'est ça qui me
dérange c'est à dire que là vous allez
dire que je repars encore de la réforme
des retraites mais c'est un député qui
nous faisait un ancien ministre pardon
qui nous faisait remarquer ça cette
semaine une dizaine mais on est en train
de parler d'une loi retraite qui est
bête comptable enfin qui a pas vraiment
un intérêt visionnaire et on se pose pas
la question de ce que chat GPT va faire
sur le travail oh ça peut supprimer des
emplois lui il disait par la machine non
d'ailleurs peut-être même des
journalistes et puis il y a les il y a
la question il y a la question aussi de
savoir et il disait quelque chose de
très intéressant c'est un journaliste de
mon service qui a recueilli ces propos
il expliquait cet ancien ministre il
disait mais comment on fait pour que
Jack j'ai pété
cotise à notre système social c'est ces
questions là et je et je trouve ça assez
intéressant c'est comment ça s'imbrique
c'est ces questions là qu'il faut se
poser et je et je pense qu'on est
totalement à côté c'est-à-dire qu'on
regarde on regarde des débats on regarde
ça de loin avec des yeux un peu effarés
on est dans d'empêcher nos enfants de
copier des de copier des textes sur
chaque GPT mais ça s'arrête à peu près
là et c'est vrai qu'on est on est pas
très visionnaire je trouve dans le débat
à contexte vous allez être remplacé par
le chat JPT
le contexte a déjà toute une partie data
en fait donc oui ça c'est vrai on
considère que le journalisme
traditionnel c'est-à-dire le recueil
d'information auprès des politiques en
assistant aux audiences aux auditions
doit être complété par le travail de
Data donc oui et en fait c'est assez
marrant parce que moi je vois dans ma
rédaction que j'ai rejoint il y a un an
qui a une fascination pour chat de GBT
c'est un effet de génération c'est une
rédaction assez jeune et moi c'est cette
fascination qui m'interroge parce que en
réalité je me dis c'est un progrès
technologique donc je n'étant pas
réactionnaire je l'accueille par
définition avec enthousiasme en revanche
ça doit nécessairement cette fascination
m'interroge mais Emmanuel Macron à
tweeter d'ailleurs vous savez à la
question avec chat geppetti donc est-ce
que derrière cette fascination il faut
pas comme dissoisigue pensez aux enjeux
de régulation et dans ces cas-là il faut
un accompagnement philosophique je pense
vous avez totalement raison sur ce que
vous dites
c'est une conception d'une intelligence
mécanique mais alors ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas lui confier ni discernement
niçois moral donc il n'en est pas
capable de toute façon mais voilà il
faut que il faut avoir une réflexion
philosophique une éducation une
réflexion sociale sur ses conséquences
et donc tout ça c'est de la régulation
vous avez dit je ne suis pas
réactionnaire est-ce que le débat se
pose aujourd'hui en ce thème entre dans
ces termes entre progressistes et
réactionnaire Nathan ah oui oui pour
ceux qui sont pour ces innovations et
ceux qui sont contre qui sont des
réactionnaires je pense que d'abord la
crainte des machines juste de c'est un
vieux thème réactionnaire il y a pas que
des réactionnaires qui ont pu la voir
même parfois des auteurs de des gens de
gauche ont pu être effrayés par par le
train par la mal à locomotive la machine
à vapeur mais c'est vrai que c'est un
thème fondamentalement et même c'est un
affect fondamentalement réactionnel
alors c'est vrai ensuite que quand il y
a une révolution comme ça je comprends
qu'il y a des gens qui puissent avoir
peur et ça c'est tout à fait normal mais
si vous voulez l'erreur ce serait de
vouloir revenir au monde d'avant une
révolution ça marche jamais comme ça la
technique elle passe enfin elle emporte
tout sur son passage elle reconfigure le
monde et donc il faut comme disait
Sartre considérer chaque époque comme un
absolu et se dire dans l'absolu de notre
époque comment faire pour aller de tel
ou telle direction avec cette révolution
qui est celle en l'occurrence de
l'intelligence artificielle demain d'une
autre donc je suis d'accord avec vous on
avance comme chaque semaine on va
terminer cette émission par un toplock
je vous pose une question très simple à
tous les quatre qui a marqué l'actualité
de la semaine en bien ou en mal choisi
que vous commencez votre top de la
semaine
j'ai deux j'ai deux tops non j'ai j'ai
pas de top en fait j'ai deux flops
désolé je vais vous décevoir c'est pour
ça alors mon premier flop c'est le
rapport de Ligue 1 sur les crèches on en
a parlé mais pas tellement dans le
contexte actuel et je trouve que ça pose
une question vertigineuse c'est-à-dire
comment on gère la vue en collectivité
les personnes vulnérables on a beaucoup
parlé des personnes âgées mais il y a la
question aussi des enfants c'est c'est
je trouve que c'est une pour ce qui est
une société ce qu'elle ces personnes
âgées et tes enfants vulnérables en
crèche le rapport est terrible on a sur
la maltraitance sur la maltraitance des
enfants dans certaines crèches et je
pense que c'est des questions éminemment
politiques et qu'il est urgent de son
saisir
le deuxième flop c'est très politique
c'est Boris Ravignon le il devait être
conforté à la tête de la présidence de
l'ADEME l'Agence de l'environnement et
de la maîtrise de l'énergie or les
députés fallait parlementaires ont
décidé de retoquer sa nomination c'est
un signal faible mais quand même assez
important je trouve pour l'exécutif les
parlementaires de la majorité sont
démobilisés c'est pas obligatoirement un
rejet du président de la République mais
il y a quand même des grosses
inquiétudes notamment après le 49-3 on
l'entendait à babouis et là on en a une
apparition Nathan top flow je crois que
vous avez deux tops aussi c'est ça j'ai
un top et un flop alors le top c'est que
dans la bibliothèque du Vatican on a
trouvé un nouveau chapitre de la Bible
c'est quand même incroyable qu'on a
trouvé je crois avec du laser qui était
entre deux pages d'un livre et c'est un
nouveau chapitre enfin c'est une
nouvelle version d'un chapitre de
l'Évangile de Mathieu donc c'est quand
même c'est quand même fou de je j'en
fais j'en fais mon top alors le flop ça
n'a rien à voir
mais c'est le rapport de l'INSEE sur
l'absence d'évolution de revenus dans
les ménages entre 2003 et 2019 donc ça
signifie que pour un même individu qui
avait tel revenu en déclaré au fisc en
2003 dans 71% des cas il reste à peu
près dans la même échelle de revenus en
2019 me semble-t-il ça éclaire sur la
crise du sens dans le monde du travail
on parle souvent du fait que les métiers
de vocation sont en crise que voilà mais
il y a aussi là on voit bien une inertie
une forme de stagnation qui est
préoccupante Virginie votre top votre
flop alors moi c'était un top un flop
mais je l'ai plutôt centré autour de
personnalité pour moi le top c'est en
tout cas l'élection de Sophie Binet ses
premiers pas à la tête de la CGT parce
que je trouve que ça elle fait un peu un
sans faute elle renouvelle beaucoup je
trouve le paysage syndical au moment où
on est sur un vrai conflit social où il
y a besoin où il y a une inter syndicale
unie elle pour moi elle fait un sans
faute en fait depuis son élection et
puis c'est une femme à la tête de ce
syndicat je trouve que c'est un très bon
signal de renouvellement et votre flop
mon flop c'est on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure Donald Trump j'ai été vraiment
saisi de la vulgarité de ses propos on
les avait oublié on se souvenait de ses
propos sur les femmes pendant la
campagne et là ça revient Philippe votre
top votre flop rapidement s'il vous
plaît le top c'est le CAC 40
ce qui est complètement lunaire enfin
honnêtement je pense que aucun d'entre
nous même sans connaître quoi que ce
soit à la Bourse aurait pu imaginer que
un an après la guerre en Ukraine compte
tenu de l'augmentation considérable des
prix des perturbations enfin c'est fou
de penser que la bourse n'a jamais été
aussi haut alors qu'il y a quand même
des menaces très considérables il y a
des explications techniques typiquement
en France on a beaucoup d'entreprises
qui se projettent beaucoup à
l'international qui sont dans le luxe
etc donc mais enfin c'est tout de même
assez impression et le flop alors là
pour le coup c'est pour moi ça a pas été
difficile de choisir cette année c'est
mettre cette semaine c'est maître Gims
et où d'ailleurs je sais pas si il faut
pas dire Cyril Hanouna parce que Cyril
Hanouna lui a donné un plateau
formidable en disant on se demandant si
après tout maître Gims avait pas raison
ce qui est tout de même assez
surréaliste et donc maître Gims je
rappelle pour ceux qui auraient raté cet
épisode formidable de l'histoire de
l'humanité je pense que les Égyptiens
avaient l'électricité grâce aux
pyramides et que il y avait des
chevaliers en Afrique mais qu'on le
cache et cetera alors oui peut-être
faut-il assez complètement dingue mais
peut-être maintenant faut-il le préciser
virgule ce qui est faux c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à tous les cas
d'avoir participé salut à vous derrière
votre écran me dit dans l'oreillette que
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux pour
nous regarder merci président l'archet
je rappelle que puis nous voir en replay
et en podcast on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même jour même heure et même
endroit bye bye
[Musique]